the big question though is if you are
going to the game do you have your
flamingos ready it's an odd question but
it doesn't make sense it's a relatively
new winning tradition for the golden
knights involves throwing plastic
flamingos right out of the ice but who
started it all Candace Charles was live
this morning inside T-Mobile Arena right
at ice level with flamingos 101. Candace
good morning
John it is cold as ice here in the bench
where the players hang out and I've got
my Flamingo though to keep me warm yes
you'll see some of these on the ice
after the nights when but why why I have
the man behind it all Drew Johnson thank
you so much for joining us tell us a
little bit about how you got this
started and why really why flamingos
absolutely so it's been a hockey
tradition for years that people throw
you know animals on the ice after team
wins or the rally the team and instead
of dead catfish
rats rights who does that something fun
something Vegas see something catchy of
course okay Casino the road uh but also
when a player lifts up his leg it's
called a flamingo so I thought yeah it's
sort of a double meaning and uh a lot of
people here have these in the yards I
thought it would be the perfect thing
it's bright it's fun it's kitchy's Vegas
it absolutely is and I know the players
get involved with this now as well yeah
one of my favorite things is the players
will pick them up and give them to fans
and Riley Smith is great about scoring
flamingo
yes yeah it's a lot of fun we need those
flamingos tonight what have you been
thinking about the season this year
how's it going it's been great it's been
like the first year a lot of people sort
of wrote us off and we've been The
Underdogs and we've uh made it all the
way here and tonight we're going to win
the Stanley Cup I love it yes we're
gonna win you guys so I can feel that
energy we're gonna do one of these
no just kidding okay I promise I won't
throw it on there right now but we do
we'll do a little bit of something one
two three go Knights go for now from
T-Mobile Arena I'm Candace Charles 8
news now yeah Candace I think if you
throw a flamingo on the ice right now
the NHL will they're gonna come after
her yeah well but we know you got to
throw like a frisbee you don't want to
take the beak off that's the move it's
important thank you Candace